that is the crisis that is our southern
border an unmitigated mess
for two straight months the u.s set
records for illegal border crossings
the worst numbers in over two decades
according to nancy pelosi border czar
kamala harris
has a completely under control let's see
she said she wasn't briefed on it she
hasn't been to the border
i don't quite see what nancy's seeing
but unlike vice president harris
our own sarah carter now has been down
to the border
numerous times up close and personal
bringing us different investigative
reports regularly
she joins us now with the latest
investigative report
in texas tonight sarah carter
yeshaw and just to give you an idea of
what's been happening here and just
today
the mexican military mexican marine
corps units were actually on the other
side
of the river actually apprehending what
they call coyotes or smugglers on the
other side
there were families on the other side of
the river that were frightened
and afraid and this is an area here in
del rio texas
where people have been crossing by the
hundreds by the hundreds daily
and especially this week so it was
interesting to see that crackdown
but the democrat mayor of del rio texas
has a strong
message for president joe biden uh his
democrat
colleague and i want you to hear what he
had to say
so this administration is telling the
american people tax-paying citizens
that that it's under control how is an
increase at 396 percent
under control when this time last year
there was approximately 18 000 detainees
we're at 97
000 in this sector alone does it upset
you that
the majority of media isn't even
covering absolutely there's no
accountability there's no
um that there's no deterrence there's no
you've got to slap on the wrist
you capture and you release it's that
simple
and they're sending that message home
sending it home i was elected to do a
duty
and that was to protect my community and
if it means calling out
a person from the same party then so be
it i am not going to back down
sean you can hear the frustration in
this democrat mayor's voice he really
wants the administration to listen right
now i'm here
at harris ranch it's in uvalde county i
spoke today to a rancher
john sewell who said that his
frustration
is spilling over like everyone else here
in the county
they feel like they're not being heard
they feel like the president isn't
paying attention
they feel like the vice president has
never been here is not listening
to them and they want the rest of
america to understand
what they're actually going through
listen to the frustration in john's
voice as he describes
what they are going through every single
day here
in his county and on his ranch
i want you to describe to me what's been
happening over the past three months
well you know i i would just say it's
it's an unprecedented migration i've
never seen it this
this bad i've been here 25 years what i
don't want
is is all the problems you know we're
hearing the stories of guns and we're
hearing the stories of
confrontation confrontation we're
getting
confrontational the people are getting
confrontational with us
that's not the norm you afraid that you
might lose your way of life here oh for
sure
yeah for sure i mean it's we've already
lost our way life
you know every day having to battle this
go to bed at night and
know that there's two four six or eight
of them coming up your fence potentially
coming to your house
sean i spoke to so many families out
here families that are terrified
they say look they've always had people
migrating across the border but it's
never been like this
they have literally men showing up at
their doors banging on their doors in
the middle of the night
they they want to protect their children
many of the ranchers out here feel alone
but the most important message that they
have for president biden
and for the white house is get a plan
together get a plan make it public
and bring them in on it they want this
resolved